hey guys Pete peppers here and this is a
candy crush jelly saga level 199
commentary walkthrough this is a pretty
tough level most people say it's a
toughest level in the latest episode so
I wanted to add some tips and I'm gonna
be pausing as I go here because the
first time I got through it I got
through a pretty pretty wasn't that bad
I mean I knew that we're at a serious
disadvantage here against licorice Larry
so I was able to set up you know what I
needed to to be able to blow up the
blockers which is our biggest you know
problem here you can see we only have
two slots for our monk links and he has
three so he could actually stack them
more than we can and he doesn't have
thick blockers on his so we have to be
pretty pretty strategic so I ended up
getting a big bomb in this one but you
know don't think that you have to do
that I mean obviously it helps but if
you watch my first video which I'll put
a link for at the end in a card you know
you'll see that I did it without a big
bomb the first time so go ahead and
start playing and in the beginning we
well through all throughout the entire
level we obviously want to clear these
blockers up here but in the beginning
the other thing you want to think about
is clearing out all the coils at the
bottom so you know some well you know
some moves we won't be able to do
anything like that one that wasn't
really very effective move but once we
clear out these blockers we have a way
better chance and another thing we want
to do is we want to get our stun up
because that will actually help us get
through down here and the reason why
that when the blockers are gone it helps
is you know when we have more chances to
get more combos but the other thing is
is that towards the end we don't we only
start with 20 moves so towards the end
we're gonna actually get into this
situation most of the time where we have
to set up orange matches in the Cascade
so that we can collect among Klingon
every single turn
because we just won't have any turns
left and I'll talk about that when we
get to that so you know collecting the
orange isn't as important here because
they're gonna be blocked from falling
anyway so we can only have two stacked
up so if you can't you know hit if you
can't make a fish or a stripe that's
gonna hit one of these two blockers up
here think about some sort of situation
where you can clear the coils as fast as
possible you know here I'm gonna make
this striped I guess it's not really
that helpful because it's not in the
right row but it does increase my stun
and then we run out of we can't really
make any more any more combos anyway so
we don't get the super stun but we did
use the stun to clear this space out and
set off that special one now we have a
little more room and you need to keep
track of how many moves you have left
because there becomes a point when
you're playing this where you just don't
have any possible chance anymore and
again I'll explain that more when we get
to it
but right now you know you can see
things aren't going that great I haven't
had any real real effective moves but we
still have 14 moves left so that's okay
we're not in the danger zone as far as
like whatever you know when we can't
finish it anyways but um you know making
fish is always good increases the stun
and sometimes they can get set off
automatically which you know gets you
hits without wasting a move to do that
so that's another thing to think about
and here's what like I said I got a big
bomb I was actually trying to set up
that space
but um obviously I didn't plan on
getting a coloring candy + color bomb
but I was going to trash this video and
play it again and then it actually
turned out that there a lot of the other
things that I wanted to stress in the
the walkthrough came up anyways so I'm
gonna hold it again we cleared out our
our blockers which is good and we have
ten moves left alright so one of the
things is that once you clear these two
blockers in the beginning you you
generally get three monk Ling's because
you'll have one sitting in each blocker
and then you'll also have the one that's
filled up and waiting to fall and once
it falls now it goes straight across the
string so we have ten moves here which
is pretty good but we're not in the like
safe zone by any means because the we
have to finish before we get six right
because you can't fill the meter up more
than full so after you have to you have
to have the move end in order for them
unclean to fall so once we get to six if
we can't collect a monthly on every
single move then we won't get it we
won't be able to finish so that's why I
decided to keep this video anyways even
though I had a big bomb because there's
a lot of interesting spots that talk
about how we can do that so here you
know this is a simple one we want to
make wrapped candies because they lead
to cascading right so you can see that
we had nose orange orange collected at
the beginning of that but because the
whole board kind of shifted down for us
we got a nut we got it fully filled up
like there isn't a match that we can
make with orange that's gonna like fill
it all the way up maybe a color bomb
match but the a for a for candy match
doesn't quite fill it up like that was a
three and you can see how far it filled
it up so we all we want to make a good
match with orange to collect orange but
we also want to get things to fall so
here we'll make a we'll make a striped
and that fills it up
and the monk Ling falls we have a stun
so that's good but we have to be careful
that we don't do this sort of thing too
much because the stun isn't going to
help us if we get below the thing we
have five so we have to pick up one on
pretty much every move after this right
because we're gonna get one here and
we're still gonna have four moves left
but we only have we can only have one
more one more move that doesn't collect
a monk link and as you can see there
isn't much here is a good example though
hold that for a second what we had was
by making the blue we could see that
we're gonna set it off and we're gonna
set off this big chain reaction of stuff
falling and that fills up our orange
candy so you might want to go back and
look at that again but we have our stun
all the way up but now we don't really
have many orange candies that are close
to each other on the board anywhere so
what do we do this green one will make a
big hole at the bottom and cause things
to fall and even though we didn't
collect a lot you can see we did get
four which almost filled it up and we
used up our last chance to not get one
so we're gonna have to really plan these
last two moves here I think here we
could probably do just about anything in
the middle because we have all these
fish and stuff and we only need like to
collect one match we don't have to get
that lucky the Striped of the fish I
like the best oh because it clears out
the whole row that it hits Plus since we
had our super stun it actually set
things in motion to get to get that in
the middle and so now we just have to
plan our last move to make sure we get
it and I was actually really worried
whenever I got to this because I was
like oh man tell me I'm not gonna make
it
with the super bomb not early and still
not finish the level so you have a lot
of different choices here you know you
could make the vertical stripe that'll
almost fill it up because it's for it's
a for orange candy match and then you
know hope that we get another match
above we can make the fish here and hope
that that gets set off some way we could
just match this blue fish in this orange
you know the orange candy would fall and
hopefully you know some more would fall
with it and set that off but you know
it's definitely a it's definitely a spot
where you want to pause because you're
not going to get in it that often you
know I mean so I thought about it for
quite a bit of time here and then I
decided that I would go for this and
then all I need is you know one extra
collection in the process and I ended up
getting it when it fell so the tips for
this you know I kind of went through
them all but I'll just summarize them
here you know obviously if you can get a
big combo in the beginning that's fine
but don't don't waste a lot of moves
trying to set it up okay you just don't
have enough and you're just not gonna
get it off to enough I don't think
instead think about clearing out the
bottom half of the board and in that and
doing that after you check for stripes
aimed at our blockers or just regular
fish matches you use your your super
stun move carefully whenever you have a
chance to do that and you know don't
really worry too much about Larry like
he will finish sometimes but we don't
have enough moves to like sit around
planning on blocking him so you know
just just play and if he if you know
every I've seen him finished it a few
times but I wasn't going to finish that
way either and then another thing is if
you get the three month clings in the
beginning and then you get below six
moves and you haven't had another one
you can just go ahead and quit save
yourself the frustration and then just
really try to plan things out so that
you can set up cascades to catch catch
oranges when you don't have the perfect
setup you know make matches at the
bottom if nothing
I look for matches that are gonna be
two-way where you're gonna get like a
big space cleared out which is gonna
give more chance of more stuff happening
than the candies fall on the board so I
hope you get hope you found this helpful
please subscribe to my channel and like
the video all that kind of stuff really
helps and I appreciate it I'll make new
videos like this one as soon as
something comes along and I'll talk to
you soon